du soleil et du monde dans les rues de
dijon ce samedi c'est ce qu attendaient
depuis longtemps les commerçants du
centre-ville et dz aussi pour compenser
leur chiffre d'affaires due aux
mouvements des gilet jaune
la préfecture vient justement d'annoncer
l'adoption de trois mesures
l'étalement de la dette fiscale le
report du paiement de leurs cotisations
des quatre premiers mois de l'année et
de leurs charges sociales
jean pierre tient salon coiffure aux
abords de la place de la république
chaque samedi ils ferment boutique avant
les débordements pour lui ce geste de
l'état n'est pas suffisant c'est le
minimum qu'on peut attendre c'est des
reports
c'est bon ça peut arranger les gens
maintenant ce n'est qu'un report
l'impact sur le commerce
va être durable c'est sur le commerce du
centre-ville c'est une catastrophe
un avis partagé place de la libération
autres lieux de passage de gilet jaune
par ce commerçant son chiffre d'affaires
a chuté de 40%
il faudrait aussi des mesures qui soient
des mesures pécuniaire parce que la
situation est gravissime alors la
préfecture annonce aussi qu'elle incite
les commerces à ouvrir le dimanche
est on en train de nous refuser de
travailler le 1er mai moi je fais une
annonce l'agent dit aidez nous laissez
nous travailler le 1er mai c'est hyper
important pour travailler le 1er mai
comme lui plusieurs commerces du
centre-ville ont sollicité la préfecture
il reste pour l'instant sans réponse
mais compte ouvrir malgré tout une
infraction passible d'une amende de 750
euros